anastasia brought her son to this
hospital in the city of zapporigia two
weeks ago
five-year-old volodymir was suffering
internal bleeding and in a critical
condition
he is recovering well
but there has been heavy shelling in the
town where they live and they can't get
back because of the russian army advance
you see
of course i'm worried i have three other
children at home there has been shelling
and they're hiding in the basement
newborn babies in incubators line the
corridor doctors have moved them here to
shield them if there's russian army
shelling
this area is protected from shrapnel if
there was a blast
so we put the babies here it is deep
inside the building between two walls
vyasha slav leads us into the basement
[Music]
hospital staff are preparing beds the
room feels cold and damp
they fear for children who cannot be
moved from the intensive care unit if
the shelling starts
there they all have terminal diseases
they're
incurable
so we have to leave them them here
in case of
air alert
because
they depend on they are dependent on
oxygen they are dependent on
resuscitation equipment and we cannot
transport everything
necessary for them
there
outside volunteers are filling sandbags
to strengthen doorways and protect the
windows if shells explode nearby
we leave the hospital
navigating walls of tank traps being set
up across the city to stop a russian
advance
we head towards anastasia's town
the road is empty
the ukrainian military tells us the
greatest threat is air strikes from
russian military drones
in the last 10 minutes or so we've heard
what sounds like a heavy barrage of grad
rockets being fired in an area behind me
that's towards the city of vasilivka
which we understand is being fought over
by ukrainians and russian forces
also in the last few minutes we've
spoken to a couple of people that tried
to deliver aid into the town they said
they were turned back by the army
because of the shelling charles
stratford al jazeera
near vasilevka eastern ukraine